un territoire en majorité rurale mais
qui compte le chef lieu du département
la première circonscription de l'yonne
celle d'auch s'est refusé c'est un peu
plus de 112 mille habitants elle couvre
la puisaye forterre l'aillantais le
coulant joies et ses vignobles mais
aussi l'auxerrois auxerre et son marché
du centre ville
ce matin là guillaume larrivé enchaîne
poignées de main bises et autres
discussions dans la partie en campagne
avec une partie de son équipe
le député sortant les républicains et
ici en terrain connu
son credo être dans l'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale face à mouscron et
son gouvernement
il faut qu'on réussisse il faut
débloquer notre pays
faut pas bloquer le quinquennat il faut
redresser notre pays
débloquez notre pays encourager tous
ceux qui veulent travailler tous ceux
qui veulent avancer défendre notre
territoire
tout simplement parce qu'on aime la
france parce qu'on a envie que la france
soit à nouveau au mouvement
autre marché en puiser cette fois ci à
saint fargeau autres candidats et autre
partie est investie par la république en
marche pour l'audace il va mourir
raconte sur la dynamique macron pour
être élu député et médecin à saint
sauveur en plus et maire de crest ni
l'homme se présente pour la première
fois la députation et veut incarner le
renouvellement de la classe politique
ma tête n'est pas connu
sur le tract mais elle est connue en
vrai aujourd'hui c'est vous sur le trac
j'ai pas l'habitude de porter de cravate
donc ça surprend un peu de voir hors
contexte mais agréablement puisque
encore une fois moi je défends la
position d'homme du territoire d'homme
de terrain un homme qui travaille avec
qui fait des choses pour la collectivité
la puisaye toujours mais à charny dans
cette commune rurale
marine le pen est arrivé en tête aux
deux tours de la présidentielle
ludovic vigreux candidat front national
tout législatives sait pouvoir compter
ici sur un solide socle d'électeurs des
habitants qui dit se sentir oublié
délaissé mais le candidat frontiste côte
tout autant sur son ancrage local
personnel moi je suis enraciné sur sur
la circonscription depuis toujours j'y
suis né je suis chef d'entreprise à
toucy à auxerre j'ai toute la légitimité
pour représenter nos compatriotes à
l'assemblée nationale
retour à auxerre et au qg du candidat de
la france est soumise
mathieu dubois grave a été investi par
le parti de jean luc mélenchon
professeur des écoles âgé de 33 ans
c'est sa toute première campagne il
reçoit ici des représentants syndicaux
des pompiers de l'yonne
faute de moyenne il a établi son qg chez
son frère mais le jeune homme ne manque
pas d'ambition pour cette élection au
niveau national clairement l'ambition
qui est affichée c'est d'être
majoritaires à l'assemblée
après au niveau de la circonscription de
l'yonne nous notre ambition ouvrant
chaque chose en son temps déjà on va
essayer de faire ce qu'il faut pour
arriver est au deuxième tour et puis une
fois qu'on sera deuxième tour et là on
verra on verra et décide visera plus
loin autre local de campagne au coeur du
centre ville celui de maud navarre
candidate europe ecologie les verts et
du ps
la jeune cosea municipal d'auxerre
viennent tout juste de recevoir tracts
fascicules et programme avec une poignée
d'amis et de soutien elle prépare les
prochaines réunions publiques
son ambition rassemble les sensibilités
et dépasser les étiquettes politiques
les bannières politiques sont pas si
importante que ça mange envie de dire
quelle que soit la manière l'important
c'est l'engagement personnel pour le
territoire est de ce point de vue moi je
pars en campagne avant tout parce que je
suis
quelqu'un qui issus de la
circonscription je suis né dans la
circonscription
je suis originaire d'iran si à quelques
kilomètres d'auxerre je suis né dans une
famille de petits viticulteurs et donc
j'ai cet engagement de terrain dans
cette circonscription dossiers refusés
le député sortant le candidat dedans
marche et celui du front national
pourrait se retrouver au second tour
dans une triangulaire
reste à savoir qui arrivera à rassembler
les douze ennemis % des suffrages
nécessaires pour passer le premier tour
surtout si l'abstention est forte et les
autres candidats de cette
circonscription sont sylvie manigod pour
lutte ouvrière véronique montini pour
l'upm anna content pour des élèves
françoise gatel charlier pour 100%
ramassant une masse pour le pnj nordine
bouche-trou et mathieu porcher